tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono felice per supportarli col codice
che deturpa vj tv su geometri dash
non è vero supporta e si non c'entra
niente però ci avevo questo sfondo
quindi supportate mi facciamo prima così
lo sfruttiamo la gloria rv una cosa
molto importante
oggi proviamo i miei livelli di geometri
nasce come abbiamo promesso nello scorso
episodio lescot andiamo a provare i miei
livelli di geometri dash che ce ne sono
un sacco pista dalla diamo su cerca
vediamo
fammi vedere cosa succede fa vj
challenge pieno ce ne sono da 10.000
siete pazzi no vabbè ragazzi sono 10
mila pagine di livelli siete
completamente impazziti come preside ci
sia così tanta gente ha fatto così tanti
livelli per me facciamo trigila passerà
questo mi piace grazie per il nome
proviamo ecco la pasta e non ce l'ho
perché non lo vinco in questo senso
style hai chiamato così per questo aiuto
io beh va beh casinò aiuto non devi
infierire sul fatto che non me la dà
nessuno esce nel senso che abita diamoci
porco demoni un casino suo livello e se
non riusciamo a fi andiamo in questo
apre non è uno randomico davvero questo
ciao amico mio grazie per fatto livello
per me oggi ti faccio vedere come fare i
cambi a livello fa vj ti prego vai tipo
timido
in che senso cosa mi prendi cosa vuoi a
me se mi fai di arrivare il copyright ti
ammazzo ti mette un mi piace sulla
fiducia e proviamo
mettete mi piace anche voi sono
fiduciosi le schiacciava di scommetto
dislike fortissimo con problemi che cosa
ti tua mamma ti picchiava da piccolo
spiegami che problemi cos'è cos'è
ma no ma siete pazzi e completamente
riusciti di cervello
raga ma sapete questo livelli che non
riuscirò mai a fare bene
basta orribile era bellissimo ma
orribile per me nel senso che non
riusciva mai a farlo filippo dami
soddisfazione filippo dami soddisfazione
no non me la sento
non me la stai dando di nuovo adesso mi
hai data scherzavo
filippo cavarne bravo bravo una sega
proprio su permesso di poter finire
non è vero filippo fermate te lo dico io
sei pazzo parco demonio incastrato tutti
gli angoli bui e tempestosi
no ragazzi ma impossibile
concentrazione ok adesso devo fare il
tag tags perfetto ora devo andare subito
sopra porco demonio io lo vedo come si
fa e non riesco pur vedendo già avete da
superare diretta difficile con un
capisci cosa devi fare
però quando vedi cosa devi fare non
riesci lo stesso parco demonio
quando non capisci capisci il tuo limite
di gila test dai perché sono così vicini
l'uno l'altro è veramente difficile
ragazzi per stare zitto e filippo hai
fatto un casino
[Musica]
solo basta non ci credo
filippo te prego non fa cagate ecco lo
sapevo 53 per cento è impossibile dai
dai dai
lo so come si fa lo so come si fa come
faccio a sbagliare pur sapendo lo so poi
il santino piccolo piccolo piano piano
piano ok no
come faccio a essere così stupido
[Musica]
piano piano
[Applauso]
nome non è possibile non posso essere
così rincoglionito di traverso qualcosa
la mia anima probabilmente porta
allora ragazzi il problema sta che mi è
saltato il tasto della tastiera
quindi devo rimettere il tasto quindi
lory me lo rimettiamo lo rimettiamo
perfetto è a posto
no è che questo gioco non è proprio
tranquillo non adatto per se avete
problemi di calma grazie filippo per
avermi rotto tra stress che ci sarò per
sempre devi fare se in debito con me di
una tastiera proculo ne riparliamo
quando scegliamo gli dico io ti odio
è una persona che non voglio mai
incontrare la mia vita sappilo porca
vacca sappino
filippo lunga cercare ti prego
piano ma da ma potevi metterli un pelino
più distanti questo
[Musica]
guardo
ciao
incredibile nuovo record ciò filippo
j e tutto questo nonostante l'edificio e
[Musica]
sono contento sollecita pc non l'avrei
mai detto ma grazie filippo per avermi
rotto un polso e la tastiera però sei
una gran brava persona mi ricorderò di
te
bobo lo penso sia bobo lo faccio solo
perché si chiama popolo e mi piace il
tuo nome si hai fatto un livello di
emissioni incrociare gli occhi
tantissimo è deciso così ho deciso che
il mio benessere visivo non doveva
essere preservato fa vj grazie amico mio
l'importante che ho finito almeno c'è il
benessere di non tirare pugnalata alla
scrivania poi per il resto va beh grazie
boboli ci prova il livello 2
ok a un casino per hotels è reso conto
ma e non clicco niente lo fai da solo
sapete che rilassante volare così dopo
un sacco di livelli dove il mio cervello
è sì è spappolato quindi volare in
questa maniera senza ostacoli per me
e un momento è il momento pausa possa
giocare ad occhi chiusi e geometrica ci
sono fortissimi sarebbe veramente da
stronzi se mettesse un muro fortissimo
adesso dove io questo casino cpc
schianto sopra salve incredibile
guadagneresti tutta la mia stima e il
mio odio allo stesso tempo però ne
varrebbe la pena
che bello raga io amo fare video
suggerito di lascio mi piace perché è
uno dei pochi giochi che negli anni è
rimasto sempre figo bari o soprattutto
fa vige infatti fattibile questo è
fattibile non è fattibile con un
attimino era fatto lui quando ha scritto
al titolo
[Musica]
mammamia questo schivato perfetto puoi
vedere che lo sai fare
che devo fare lì cos'è sta roba non li
uso cio paura suoi
[Musica]
non vi sto usando ci ha paura a iasi non
so grafia è finita la iscritto al
contrario
[Musica]
no in mamma mia stiamo distraendo sarai
morto d'altissimo ho fatto un livello
fattibile e sono contento di questo
parigi è un grande ragazzo di concludere
grazie mille per il complimento
spero che sia un livello zhao jing cioè
di quelli dove mori spesso dice meno
inizio tra 20 anni
io sono contentissimo è fatto che
abbiate battutisti livelli per me e non
l'avevo non me n'ero mai ha scorto la
corte adesso potranno cercare i livelli
per nome porca vacca sono stato stupido
grazie davvero a prezzo questo è
l'ultimo tentativo che faccio se riesco
bene sono bagni ma spero che fini sia
piaciuto ragazzi iscrivetevi al canale
schiacciata la campanella per rimanere
aggiornati su tutti i video che escono
perché sono schiacciate a campanella un
casino e noi ci vediamo l'anno prossimo
video aspetta un attimo che però vede
tedesca pirlo iscrivetevi anche al
secondo canale grazie mille per il
supporto ragazzi che vi state dando in
questi giorni
io vi amo e non sto parlando a vanvera
semplicemente perché devo dire qualcosa
mentre livello avanti ma perché sto fare
e vi voglio bene che ne pensate ragazzi
delle mezze stagioni
secondo me non sono più come una volta e
la scuola è veramente importante perché
è finito il video è finito che vi sia
rifiuto livello sono contento no
veramente un cap artistica ci pensavo ci
fossero solo livelli personalizzati su
happy with e invece no anche i geometri
se volete farne di altri fatemeli che
magari giocando nel prossimo e cosa è
piaciuto abbiamo già fatta manfrinato
bei ragazzi
[Musica]